is the American Idol revival in trouble
it sure seems that way because while
auditions began today in Orlando and
Portland of big piece of the puzzle is
still missing
oh yeah like two or three pieces um why
is there such a struggle to fill the
judges seats next to Katy Perry one
thing's for sure Idol could be in crisis
mode hundreds of hopefuls lined up in
Orlando and Portland but I know Stu
doesn't have a full talent panel sign
it's leaving someone during the
production is having a talent crisis
Katy Perry the show's only confirmed
judge tweeted a photo promoting day one
of auditions in Orlando ABC did bring
out former Idol winners Jordin Sparks
Ruben Studdard and Chris Allen to pump
up the crowds it appears to be a break
from tradition because in years past
when auditions would occur in front of
judges it would trigger some of idols
biggest moments you look a little old
your dancing is terrible the singing was
horrendous ABC would not comment on
rumors of production chaos but did say
talent was never scheduled to be present
for this first round of bus tour
auditions a network executive did say
they are taking their time to find the
right chemistry to compliment their
reported $25,000,000 Katy investment
producers are planning to have all the
judges lock and present for a later
round of auditions in six weeks while
Katy is feeling a few names she would
like to join her my dream people would
be Rihanna and like Tim across it's
actually Luke Bryan and Lionel Richie
who are rumoured frontrunners
a source tells ET lino would be in all
night long quote if they can get the
timing and money right it's reported
lino once 10 million and idle is
offering around five he's like smiley
and he loves to talk daughter Nicole
Richie is all for it but his current all
the hits tour mate and former Idol judge
Mariah Carey told ET this I would say
don't do it can I just point out real
quick I don't think Ryan Seacrest is
feeling any of the idle pressure um he
posted his own version of carpool
karaoke - now horns slow hands I also
want to point out you notice Ryan's
rocking a Bentley right there he that is
what he's driving there's one or two
Bentley that's right because that
American Idol cheque has cash